that's a lot of book you know I wonder
when I hear your [__] what is your
writing process like or do you write or
do you go in and do the melody first
like yeah
but like at home the whole song
right and I'm telling you I'm gonna tell
him to keep that and I'll just put words
in so that your your first take is just
strictly strictly no matter how I feel
and I always go with the first one how I
feel it's fire and I hear from there you
probably put the words whatever I'm
humming I just make it worse yeah but I
might start right here and I might go to
the end but the middle might be over
um so I really record like it kind of
weird
really weird I might start at the end
and then go back to the front oh really
yeah that's dope yeah it just depends on
how you feeling I do that every time so
you start at the end I start right here
first I might start first then I might
let beat play I might go to the end
yeah I do like that it'd be like Beast
of peace that [__] crazy I never heard
that yeah it really it I really like
recording like that now
um because you'll be stuck on one part
you don't want to be stuck right there
so if you stuck
right yeah get stuck and then they don't
even get past them
so I had to go and get out the way
because it's actually really efficient
all right yeah because like you said if
you have like some sort of like writer's
block or you're right like hey I already
got the front and the end done so right
you're gonna have to do the middle they
got to do the middle at that point or
you at least gonna come back to it I'll
do it I like that yo talk to me what has
been your favorite experience on tour so
far
um just sharp performing but like has
there been a city or like a maybe an
after party or something like man this
city was just everything it's a it's a
super fun but that's it every city been
lit though what's the bus life like
tour bus
feel better in your bed well I heard
you're not allowed to [__] on the bus is
that true hell no I mean you can't do
that but I heard that they they try to
be like if you can wait don't [__] on
the bus I ain't even never [__] on the
bus yet but I
I told you that every rapper I know
there's always like maybe they're on
less nicer buses but they're always like
yo
the driver prefers nobody shits on the
bus because then he's got to clean this
[__] oh yeah I forgot about that so like
usually there's like you know we hit a
[__] liquor store or a truck stop or
something all right all right so yeah
what I always hear that couple of things
that people need on tour or that they're
always short on are draws and socks is
this true yeah
it'll be on the club those are like the
the Necessities right like you got you
can never have too much socks and draws
on the tour bus
are you guys playing 2K or any uh any
PS5 okay man Carl dude Call of Duty
if you were a playable character in Call
of Duty which is very possible one day
what's your like go-to gun
that look golden Little Golden
um stick golden golden AK do the golden
AKA
I feel like you could like next year we
might be like playing as Ryan Rodriguez
all right on Call of Duty Call of Duty
right it's good
they just dropped Nikki Nikki yeah Nikki
and 21 Savage
times yeah both of them yeah so two you
could be both of them I didn't see that
imagine like getting smoked by Nicki
Minaj though bro like you're like
running around and Nikki's [__] in
her pink like camo [__] you get capped
by Nicky I'll be [__] out of play
though no I'm not even talking about
that could be like a nine-year-old kid
with a headset yeah oh yeah I forget
they playing at that yeah oh yeah like
[__] man can you pick somebody else bro
to kill me with what
um who's your go-to on 2K Madden
goes on 2K
uh
the Bucks the Bucks yeah man yeah
Eagles are great because you could just
run you run though because Jalen hurts
is a monster it's almost like did you
ever play back in the day when Mike Vick
was in Madden were you old enough yeah
he was like a cheat code you don't need
to play college football oh yeah he
didn't play with his brother no he was
fat July Marcus it what team was he on
he was on Virginia Tech oh he went to
Virginia Tech too
yeah yeah that's probably why he went
are you a big uh I mean like Alabama we
only like there's no teams they're just
college football right so are you like a
college football fan yeah
what is this is it Auburn is it Alabama
Alabama
yeah have you been to one of those games
no I've been they look insane yeah they
look cool and I heard the uh the the
like uh what's it called beforehand what
did they do beforehand when they be
[__]
partying in the parking lot
tailgating I heard the tailgate [__] is
crazy yeah yeah in Alabama I heard that
[__] is lit bro
um